yoader's of everybody prestige married
you here with some more witcher 3
content the hearts of stone deal c is
out and it's time to hit up some more
videos so in this video i'm gonna be
showing you guys how to beat the toad
prince keep in mind all the gameplay you
see was for me beating him on death
march difficulty that's the hardest
difficulty so you know this is legit
alright so toad prince PS spoilers yeah
toad prince he has three main methods of
attacking you he has his tongue as
poison his jump he is in his tongue it's
long he has a long range tongue short
range tongues long range is gonna be
like quick sniper rifle it can hit you
through Quen shield and do damage to
avoid this you're gonna want to be just
keep moving don't stand directly in
front of them for more than like a
second because otherwise he's probably
just gonna use this deck if you're far
away from him farther away that you
can't hit him with your sword since if
you can hit him with your sword and you
straight in front of them he's probably
gonna use his short-range tongue attack
which is a lot a fatter of a range
except it doesn't go nearly as far and
does do a lot of damage i don't know if
this one breaks a Quen shield I kind of
forget but it does do a lot of damage
and you don't want to get hit by it so
dodge that by just not staying directly
in front of his face because if you're
standing in front of his face two inches
away from him but just you're always out
of position that is never the right
position to be in so never beat it
next up we got his poison his poison he
can cluster bomb you ain't bomb you or
short-range blast you I'm gonna talk
about the short range at the last its is
similar to the short range tongue attack
it's basically the exact same area that
I can hit you in the poison blast except
it doesn't do any damage it just makes
your screen all green so you can't see
anything doesn't owe any damage though
which is not bad so it's like it's not
too bad if you hit by it just don't be
right in front of his face that's
another thing just never be in that
position is it's bad the cluster bombs
and the aim bombs he can cluster bomb
he's just gonna stand still and just
fire like four or five bomb and randomly
throughout like an just across the area
arena you can fight him in the aim bomb
is gonna be the same bombs kept you can
aim to match you and yeah so to Dobbs
this just keep moving the aim ones are
gonna go directly at you the cluster
bombs aren't so cluster bombs are easy
to dodge because you might not even have
to just kind of keep moving and they
move really slowly so you'll be fine if
you don't stand
one thing to note out he is weak to fire
Geralt says this that he doesn't like
fire - someone throws a torch at him
he's weak to fire that means he's weak
to Agni he's weak to fire bombs like the
dancing star and he's weak to lighting
gas on fire and having to blow up now
when the cluster bomb and the aim bomb
the poison lying on the ground they
produce some gas around them this is a
similar to gas from other areas and
there's like the dragon rain bomb that's
another one that creates the gas like
this if you set the stuff on fire it'll
blow him up but keep in mind it will
damage you if we stand in it so be
careful about that now we're on to the
main course his jump he's not like have
what he does to attack you is just to
jump up in place he will eventually
start jumping sideways back back to back
forward backwards all that could stuff
away from you towards you but his main
jump is just gonna be up that's gonna be
his main attack if you're kinda near him
he's just gonna jump if you're not kinda
near him he's gonna jump he's just gonna
jump a lot to beat this so to say don't
stand right next to him I don't stay
standing right next to him ever I didn't
want to keep moving going in and out
when he jumps be sure to be moving
towards him as he lands so when you're
he lands you're not close to him but
right that right at that moment after
you're next to him you can get one maybe
two hits if you get used to him really
well time really well you get like two
maybe even three hits but one is the
safest I generally only went for one
because otherwise he might hit me with
any of the other close-range attacks or
he might just jump again because he
really likes jumping one thing I do want
to point out if he can hit you with his
appendages I've been hitting by a back
leg once and just it was really random I
don't know it could happen it hasn't
happened since and it's just if you're
standing right next to him and you're
not moving around and you're not moving
away from him or hitting him or even if
you're hitting them he can just hit you
with his fiendish Chancellors just gonna
jump which is easier dodge the appendage
it was kind of out of blue and probably
not gonna get too used to it unless you
find some way to get him to do a lot so
that's gonna be all of his attacks and
at least that he used on me and I fought
him for good like at least in 12 minutes
I died when my first time fighting him
and this is my second
finding him was able to take him down uh
I don't know about decoctions I use the
kid in the decoction as you can see
which gives me health whenever you stand
like signs and I really like that but
not a big decoction man you don't need a
lot of interactions I will say dancing
star is the fire bomb that I said you
use that is a really good bond it's
really powerful I was superior one and
it just destroys him so that's great you
want these bombs yeah it's great
always also PS best tip ever in this
game use Quentin when is just your
lifeline your plug your best friend your
lover
Quinn is like in with three so that's
going to be it for the video I'm just
gonna let the game play play other than
this let you watch the entire fight that
I had with the toad Prince and yeah I
hope you guys enjoyed this if you have
make sure to check out my channel for
more rich content I'm going to be
posting more rich content as I play
through more Witcher DLC hearthstone
advertisement totally JK not getting
paid this alright thank you guys peace
out
you
Halawa Galloway come gather rush I'll
root